The year was 1743, and in the manicured gardens of some English estate, a man with a beard like a winter storm sat in his hermitage, paid to be silent, paid to rot in his own solitude.
He had been hired for the performance, a living statue of melancholy, a man who existed only to be looked at, never spoken to.
And then, one evening, he vanished. No note. No warning. Just an empty hut and the faintest whisper of wind through the trees. That was the first true ghosting.
Fast forward to today. We call it the ghosting protocol. Not because it's cruel, though it is, but because it's efficient.
A surgical strike against the messy, clinging weight of human connection. You don't argue. You don't explain. You simply disappear.
And in doing so, you leave behind something far more damaging than anger. Uncertainty.
The kind that gnaws. The kind that replays itself in the quiet hours, when the mind, starved for resolution, turns over every unanswered text, every half-finished conversation, every almost goodbye.
The brain, you see, hates an open loop. Psychologists call it the Zegarnik effect. The way unfinished business clings to us like cobwebs.
A debt unpaid. A door left ajar. A relationship that was never properly ended. The ghoster knows this. They weaponize it.
By walking away without a trace, they ensure their exit is not just a departure, but a haunting.
You are no longer a memory. You are a question mark. A gap in someone's story they can never fill.
Now, how does one become a master of this art?
First, the slow fade. Not a dramatic cut-o-no. That would be too obvious.
Instead, you stretch the silence like taffy. A day between replies becomes two. Two becomes a week.
By the time you stop responding entirely, they've already accepted the pattern.
They've been trained in your absence. And when you finally vanish, it's not a shock.
It's just another chapter in a story they've already learned to dread.
Then comes the unsent message. The one you write in the dark of night, fingers hovering over the screen, ready to type the words that would make sense of it all.
But you don't. You delete it. Why? Because the truth is a currency, and once spent, it can't be recalled.
Let them drown in their own theories. Let them invent the worst possible explanation.
The more they imagine, the more they need you to correct them, and you, of course, will never answer.
After that, the mutual sunder. Block them. Not because you fear their retaliation, though you should, but because you want to hear the silence.
The way their messages bounce back, unseen. The way their calls go straight to voicemail, unanswered.
That silence is your victory. It's the sound of a bridge burning, one unreturned text at a time.
And finally, the new leaf mirage. You tell yourself this is self-care, that you're not a monster.
You're just selective, that your energy is precious, and you refuse to waste it on people who don't deserve it.
It's a neat trick, really. Frame avoidance as agency, and suddenly you're not abandoning anyone, you're liberating yourself.
While the rest of the world clings to old habits, you're already building your relational void.
A person who leaves no footprints, a presence that fades like smoke.
The result?
You become untouchable.
Not in the way of a hero, no, nothing so noble, but in the way of a ghost.
A man in a hermitage who is paid to be alone.
A question mark in someone's past.
A memory that was never allowed to settle.
You are the ultimate relational sovereign, the king of the unsaid, the architect of the void.
And the best part?
You don't even have to justify it.
Because a goodbye is a gift of closure, and you, my friend, have no intention of giving one.